VOICE OVER: This is drone racing
THOMAS BITMATTA: Think of it as somewhere
between car racing and Red Bull Air Race.
So it's a three-dimensional track but you are racing
against the clock or racing for a certain number of laps.
VO: Agile quadcopters race around 3D tracks
at breathtaking speeds, controlled remotely using
onboard cameras that stream live video to a
pilot's goggles.
THOMAS: We have a lot of acceleration where you're basically instantly hitting your
top speed or within half a second and that top
speed can be a range of 100 kilometers an hour
all the way through to above 200 kilometers anhour.
VO: Pilots need to be highly trained, have
incredible spatial awareness, and show
split second reflexes to succeed and that makes
it an exciting challenge for AI.
ELIA KAUFMANN: Most recent advances in deep reinforcement learning have
been achieved in domains that can be easily simulated
This challenge requires to push
a real physical robots to its its limits.
VO: Researchers have been training AI to race drones
for nearly a decade but they've struggled to come
close to matching human performance.
The droneneeds to understand its environment,
then it needs to understand where it is on a race track
andthen you need to master planning and control.
Good commands to send to the motors that make the drone
fly as fast as possible
VO: Until now for AI to even approach human level required an external motion
capture system similar to those used in
film production, a process which makes comparison to
human pilots difficult.
But now there's a new entry in the race
This system - called Swift - is different
it can race at the level of human world champions
using only on-board video and inertia sensors
and computation but first it needs practice
lots of practice
Swift run simulations to find thefastest route
through each of the gates that Mark out the race track
this takes Swift about an hour.
ELIA: This translates to about 23 days of 24 7 flying of this AI pilot
VO: But simulations alone aren'tenough.
The drone has to fly in the real world, and the real world comes with problems
that the dronehas to be able to adapt to as it goes.
On board the drone has two bits of kit that tell it where it
is, a camera and an inertia sensor.
Together these can estimate the velocity, position and orientation
of the drone using a method called visual inertialodometry or VIO
On its own VIO isn't accurate
enough to keep the drone on course when traveling
at the high speeds of a race cameras just don't
operate fast enough and problems like motion blur
cause the AI to drift off its course so Swift
also uses a neural network to detect and track
the location of the gates and give the drone
a much better understanding of its position.
But it isn't finished yet.
Even withthis information there are unpredictable environmental conditions that could throw thedrone off course and so Swift flies a test run,
using the kind of external motion tracking system
we mentioned before to trial its simulated route.
Swift can then compare the information from its
onboard systems with the external data and adapt
to any differences. Fine-tuning its simulation to
account for variables that are hard to model like
air turbulence or a loss of visual information
somewhere on the track.
Put it together and Swift can compete with the best pilots in the
world.
THOMAS: I did all right it did have some little inconsistency problems and that was usually whenas a human pilot you could sort of capitalize on
that and try and make an overtake but if it flew its
near perfect run and you were just a little bit
off the start you were basically just following it
the whole time and I honestly think in most club
level races with the system as it is it would
actually still outperform most human pilots
it flies that good.
VO: It can turn more sharply, race more
consistently, and plan its moves further ahead than humans
but it's not perfect, the AI pilot hasn't
been trained to recover from a collision
and it struggles if there are changes to the environment
after it has completed its test laps.
ELIA: Specifically changes in the environment in this case means
changes in illumination if we fine-tune our system
based on you know environment conditions that
are substantially different to the environment
condition that we then actually deploy the system
we saw a large drop in robustness which means that
we frequently couldn't complete the lap or that
we yeah that we that we crash into gates.
VO: even with these limitations the team thinks that this is the
first time an autonomous mobile robot has achieved
world champion-level performance in a real world
competitive sport
and they hope that this approach could be applied more broadly.
ELIA: We could speed up
drones that do search and rescue missions,
we could speed up drones that do autonomous inspections of
buildings for example
because at the end of the day a drone is limited in flight time
which meansif you want to make a drone
as useful as possible you basically need to fly fast
to maximize its
utility given the very limited battery life.